[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre 7,8
loisirs à vis de vous retrouver pour ce
douzième numéro tout de suite le
sommaire de ce jeudi 6 200 mois
le téléthon 2010 8 commence ce vendredi
de nombreuses communes se mobilisent
nous recevrons michel crétins et jean
michel noble pour vous présenter les
actions sportives de montigny le
bretonneux
les joueurs de l'équipe de football de
versailles appliquons le rc lens pour le
8e tour de l'équipe de france ce samedi
8 décembre un match sur le terrain mais
aussi dans les gradins le collectif
ultra versailles et se prépare à
affronter les supporters sang et or et
le conservatoire de plaisir et le réseau
des maisons de familles de la ville
organise le 4e concert des fans ou
fratrie ses parents sont réunis sur
scène pour interpréter des morceaux
reportages pendant les dernières
répétitions depuis quatre ans le
conservatoire de plaisir propose aux
musiciens d'une même famille de se
réunir sur scène c'est le concert des
familles il aura lieu le vendredi 7
décembre à 20 heures à la maison des
familles flora tristan nous avons
assisté aux dernières répétitions dans
la famille boots il y à la fille au
violon le fils à la trompette et la mer
au piano moi parce que j'ai vu maurice
andré ayew et du coup je choisisse à ce
que j'aime bien moi je ne sais plus
comment j'ai toujours aimé le piano donc
j'ai appris le piano
bah moi d'abord parce que je trouve que
je vais lancer sa ya une belle sonorité
et puis je trouvais que la façon dont on
tenu larcher début j'ai voulu faire ça
parce que je trouvais que j'avais une
belle tenue
ils se préparent pour la quatrième
édition du concert des familles
le conservatoire de plaisir en lien avec
les réseaux des maisons de familles de
la ville réunit fratrie et par an sur
scène j'ai repris maintenant elle est
dernière pour pouvoir essayer d'en
refaire avec l essai de la soutenir et
puis bah parce que je trouve ça sympa de
pouvoir jouer du piano avec ma fille
grâce à lui je ferais continuer le piano
encore très longtemps et j'aime bien
jouer du piano avec mon papa
un piano pour quatre frères et soeurs
une vingtaine de familles s'est inscrite
pour jouir à la maison des familles
flora tristan déjà ça nous permet aussi
de voir quatre familles qu'on peut gens
semblent s'entendre que c'est pas comme
les tricheurs fait des frayeurs qui
passe temps se discuter et tout est là
en fait c'est là en fait on est d'unir
les une seule personne en fait les
professeurs sont mobilisés pour préparer
avec eux les morceaux en s'adaptant à
tous les niveaux des débutants aux plus
confirmés
c'est ton premier morceau vers chartres
est rien ils pourront tous compter sur
leurs familles pour les soutenir et
affronter le trac de jeunes artistes
qu'il soit dans le public ou sur scène
[Musique]
c'est une année anniversaire
l'association française contre la
myopathie à 60 ans le 4 décembre 1985
cette le premier téléthon était lancé la
grande médiatisation associé à l'énorme
mobilisation du monde associatif sportif
et des entreprises est un succès la
collecte des bases les 175 millions de
francs mais revenons en 2018 pour cette
32ème édition avec nous en plateau
michel cre étant alors vous êtes
maire-adjoint de montigny le bretonneux
délégué à l'ailé sportive et jean michel
noble breizh président de la snb bonjour
alors si c'est l'univers sportif de la
ville que je reçois c'est parce qu à
montigny cette année on fait des défis
oui tout à fait c'est une année de défis
sportifs donc les déjà sur les
emplacements de deux de nos différents
défis puisque y aura deux endroits
privilégiés qui sont le gymnase pierre
de coubertin et le club le village qui
sont donc deux des entités 13 parties à
vocation très sportive de la ville dans
lequel nous aurons tout un tas
d'animations sur le à partir de vendredi
soir 17h jusque 2 jusqu'au dimanche est
donc en plus un troisième un troisième
endroit qui est la sphère du manet ou y
aura lé solide en ce samedi soir qui est
une
grande soirée de danse toujours au
profit du téléthon
alors il ya plus d'une dizaine
d'associations et des partenaires qui se
mobilisent notamment la smb avec
plusieurs sections
oui la lcb aura 18 sections sur 21 donc
se représente énormément sur les
différents jours on aura donc le
dimanche c'est le baseball il ya
plusieurs pages facebook fait pas partie
des scènes d un oui le baseball c'est le
dimanche
non la snb ce sera surtout le samedi et
le vendredi soir aussi vendredi soir au
club le village avec la soirée fluo et
le samedi après-midi bon tout
l'après-midi l'allée des sections vont
passer tout au long de l'après midi
alors justement je reviens sur cette
soirée fluo ça fait partie des
nouveautés de l'année complète par oui
c'est une c'est une nouveauté donc de ce
que nous avons souhaité c'est d'avoir
une opération assez ludique de faire une
soirée fluo qui permettent d'attirer
minutes je dirais à large panel de
participants avec dans la fois des défis
sportifs donc pour aussi bien pour les
jeunes que pour les moins jeunes
donc qui permet de rassembler énormément
de personnes c'est toujours une
nouveauté sur le avec notamment par
exemple une zone bas dans la dans la
soirée des défis en tennis de table en
tennis en mamine tonnes et c'est donc
sur sur l'ensemble de la soirée plein
plein de sports plein d'activités
sportives plein d'associations et le
lendemain sur le samedi donc on aura une
grande opération fil rouge sur un défi
de grimpe donc le
l'association ciel qui est donc
l'association de grammes de la ville va
faire tout un fil rouge sur l'ensemble
de la journée pour essayer d'atteindre
un record
et donc là chaque fois pour faire
participer le maximum de personnes et
donc l'entrée ces deux euros c'est
directement reversés à l'afm téléthon il
y aura également le mur pour chaque site
tout à fait ça fait donc 20 politique
c'est quoi c'était battre les 23000 910
euros de l'année dernière c'est ce qu'on
a c'est chaque année c'est d'essayer de
battre le record d'alain des précédentes
ça devient de plus en plus difficile
parce que on atteint des désirs des
sommes assez assez considérable pour le
nôtre pour notre ville mais nous ces
douches ne cherchant justement à travers
toutes ces animations à en faire en fait
je dirais des records en records annuels
mais l'objectif c'est à travers la
travers le téléthon d'avoir deux
d'animer la ville et de faire en sorte
que nos concitoyens se sentent concernés
et viennent participer à ce téléthon
très bien merci mais michel crétins et
jean michel noble d'être venu sur notre
plateau et compositions on le rappelle
pour faire vos dons c'est le 36 37 ou
directement sur le site internet et
d'autres communes de l'agglomération se
mobilisent vous pouvez retrouver les
programmes de guyancourt et magny les
hameaux dans le 7-8 journal de ce jeudi
c'est décembre ville preuve prévoir
large programme et la ville de
coignières réalise son premier téléthon
d'ampleur retrouvez toutes les
mobilisations sur le site internet de la
fm téléthon et sur les sites respectifs
de vos communes
noël approche et pour vous faire
patienter la commanderie vous proposant
noël décalé du 8 au 16 décembre
retrouvez expositions animations et
concerts avec des temps forts les
week-ends programme complet a consulté
sur le site internet
les marchés noël se poursuivent à saint
quentin en yvelines une cinquantaine
d'exposants s'installeront dans le parc
du château de plaisir la ville n'oublie
pas les enfants avec une patinoire un
carrousel une mini ferme et encore des
balades en calèche
évidemment le père noël sera de la
partie avant de rejoindre coignières et
sa vingtaine d'exposants et si vous ne
pouvez pas aller à sa rencontre vous
pouvez lui envoyer votre lettre
la ville de villepreux organise
d'ailleurs un concours de dessins et de
poèmes au père noël
déposez votre dans la boîte aux lettres
placerez vous avant le 21 décembre
votre rubrique dans les salles vous
invite dans un village peuplé
d'irréductibles
le gaulois cette semaine patrick jacques
de dixmude s'est rendu à l'espace
philippe noiret aux clayes-sous-bois
[Musique]
retrouvé cette semaine à l'espace
philippe noiret le film astérix et le
secret de la potion magique quand vous
propose en sortie nationale
alexandre astier donc signe ce film avec
une histoire originale
on retrouve donc les ingrédients de base
de ces personnages prennent vie et
notamment donc sediri du petit bleu
gaulois et je le césar etc et il va
ajouter comme ingrédient donc des
personnages notamment un personnage de
dos ni méchant voilà très bien très bien
dessiné et là il a reçu en salle et
leçons culinaire de d'alfred hitchcock
puisque améliorer les munitions de
minorer le film et il va aussi ajouté un
autre ingrédient alors ça je ne
dévoilerai pas mes un autre personnage
plus moderne qui va trancher un petit
peu dans l'univers un moustachu de
de la bd voilà donc c'est à retrouver
cette rue mène donc la potion magique
d'alexandre astier avec l'humour qu'on
lui connaît
cette semaine l espace et philippe
noiret
[Musique]
cros rendez vous sportif ce week end les
joueurs du fc versailles compte sur vous
pour donner de la voix en bord de
terrain ils reçoivent le rc lens ce
samedi 18 décembre à 13h30 au sablon
boron pour le 8e tour de la coupe de
france de football
pour l'occasion le collectif des ultras
versailles est habituellement sur les
bords de terrain de rugby appelle à
venir affronter le champ des corons dans
les gradins lucien gaspard ac était sur
le plateau de 7,8 journal de mercredi 5
décembre
merci beaucoup de messages de gens qui
sont d'habitude avec le fcv et qui
souhaitent venir avec nous dans le
cortège pourra monter jusqu'à la tribune
pour soutenir ce que ça va être je
pensais des plus grands moments dans le
sport versailles et si vous voyez des
victoires et donc on va donner de la
voix et on regarde on regarde le score
que à la fin du match et pendant 88 4 à
18 ans elle chantait au stade est longue
on pousse pour soutenir les joueurs du
fc la compagnie la compagnie d'arc de
magny-les-hameaux organise une
compétition de tir à l'arc en salle
l'entrée est libre pour venir observer
les archers au gymnase auguste d'hélène
samedi 8 et dimanche 9 décembre de 9
heures à 17 heures une course de petites
voitures à maurepas
le modélisme marque pas club vous donne
rendez vous pour la 12e édition des 6
heures de maurepas une course
d'endurance en équipe avec des périodes
nocturne
l'entrée gratuite et le départ est lancé
à 11 heures
[Musique]
et pour notre escapade en dehors des
frontières yvelinoise nous n'aurons donc
place de la concorde à paris
le jeu de paume expose des clichés de
doré dorothée allonge l'une des plus
grandes photographes américaines et met
en avant son travail sur la crise de
reportage de nicolas le hérissé de nos
confrères la grand paris elle est la
figure de l'amérique des années 30 une
femme et des enfants poussées à la rue
par la grande crise économique de 1929
immortalisée par dorothée à l'ange une
des rares femmes photographes de
l'époque
cette exposition au jeu de paume met en
lumière le sort tragique de millions
d'ouvriers et aviculteur victimes du
krach boursier de rota loge était une
photographe américaine qui au départ a
commencé en tant que portraitiste à san
francisco avait dans un studio de
photographe et a décidé en fait assez
rapidement au début des années 30
d'aller photographier les personnes
victimes de la crise et donc de la
grande dépression elle le dit de manière
assez claire elle dit la grande
dépression a réveillé et c'est ce besoin
donc de témoigner de leurs conditions de
vie leurs conditions de travail
donc elle va se rendre directement dans
la rue et qui ensuite recevoir des
commandes à la fois de magazines et de
l'état qui vont l'amener donc travailler
de manière plus précise avec la
population américaine
commissionné par le gouvernement
américain de l'époque dorothée allanche
parcourt les états unis de 1935 à 1941
avec ces clichés elle rencontre de la
misère du sort tragique des afro
américains victimes de la crise et du
racisme d état du sud des photographies
soigner pour être diffusé et alerter
l'opinion publique sur les injustices et
les inégalités de la société américaine
le parcours de l'exposition ce qui est
assez intéressant c'est qu'on se
rencontre au départ allait assez
peut-être mal à l'aise d'aller
photographier directement les gens comme
ça dans la rue qu'elle ne connaît pas et
progressivement la mission qui lui est
confiée pas lui donner confiance donc
elle va pouvoir expliquer sa démarche
dont va se rendre compte effectivement
qu'on va aller plutôt du côté du
portrait que les regards vont se tourner
vers elle par exemple et donc elle va
systématiquement
pensez aussi la diffusion de ces images
donc comment est ce qu'elles peuvent
être construites pour je dirais toucher
la population américaine
dorothée allonge photographiera plus
tard et les camps où après l'attaqué de
pearl harbour des milliers d'américains
d'origine japonaise ont été internés
c'est la fin de votre 7,8 loisirs merci
nous avoir suivis pour ce douzième
numéro n'oubliez pas le 36 37 pour
donner au téléthon ce week end
quant à moi je vous donne rendez vous la
semaine prochaine pour de nouvelles
idées sorties
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on